PRESENTER 1: --at
Google and LCS.
And I also am one of the--
I'm not exactly sure what
my role in this Women at
Google thing is.
I just know that I've been asked
to help recruit women
leaders, both internally and
externally, to come talk to us
occasionally--
hi guys, come on in--
so we can get you into career
paths of great women leaders,
leadership style, and just
get to expand our
network a little bit.
And a special thanks
and welcome to the
fellas who joined us.
Woo hoo!
Because I think a lot of what
Daina will talk about today is
not only relevant to women,
but for all of us.
And I think we'll all be able
to learn through her
experience.
A little background on
how I know Daina.
When I was ahoy and
running our HP
business, Daina was a client.
And there was just something
about her that I think you'll
quickly relate to after
you get to talk with
her a little bit.
That she's just someone that
people are drawn to.
And you probably don't know
this, but mentors can take on
a lot of different forms.
People who you run to
with your problems.
But I think a mentor, for me,
is oftentimes people that I
just kind of watch, and I learn
from and see how they
create relationships and
move things along.
And I think one of the biggest
lessons in collaboration that
I got was actually from Daina.
We were working on a deal,
some kind of program--
I'm not exactly sure what the
details were-- years ago.
And it was us and a creative
agency and a media agency.
Was it Project Direct?
Yeah, one of our first
engagement programs.
Daina was actually
the [INAUDIBLE].
And oftentimes you get a lot
of the infighting, and
everybody wants to
take control.
And Daina was finally
like, just everybody
get around the table.
I want Google.
I want the agencies.
You all are important.
I love you all.
We're all just going to make
this happen together.
And we'll all celebrate
in the success.
And people followed along,
because she set the tone.
I think that that is a really
good lesson for us, whether
we're working with
external teams or
internal teams or whatever.
It's like, if you can be more
inclusive, you gain the
loyalties of the people
you're working with.
And I think that's what
has set Daina as
such a great leader.
So we met at HP.
And now, of course, she's the
Global CEO of Performics.
I'm super proud of her as I've
been able to watch that.
And she's going to talk to us
today about that path and
leadership lessons
along the way.
And we'll be able to
take questions.
So I hope you enjoy Daina
as much as I do.
DAINA MIDDLETON: Thank you.
Thank you [INAUDIBLE].
So I feel like I need to just
come over here, like a
fireside chat type of thing.
And Stephanie's running
my presentation.
So thank you for having me.
Actually, it's a real treat,
both to come to Google, as
well as actually to come
to San Francisco.
I don't get to San Francisco
nearly often enough.
I used to come when
I worked for HP.
I worked for HP 16 years.
So I used to come almost every
week for 16 years.
And so I very much miss it.
For a long time, Chica--
now, see I say Chicago now.
San Francisco is like
my second home.
But now it's Chicago.
Chicago is really
my second home.
So thank you for having me.
I'll talk a little bit about
my view of the world.
But I want to leave plenty of
time for questions, for you
guys to ask me just anything.
And I'm willing to answer
nearly anything.
[LAUGHTER]
Nearly.
I am being taped, right?
OK.
So we can go on.
So I want to give you a little
bit of background, just a
refresher course on what
Performics is for those of you
who don't know.
So Performics really was born
in 1998, as one of the first
affiliate companies.
So really, it's been a
performance marketing company
its entire life and got into
both the paid search and the
organic search business within
a couple of years.
Because I think we recognized
right away that if you put all
of those pieces together, you
can better manage the holistic
performance.
Because there's a lot of overlap
within those channels.
And then very shortly after
that, we merged with a little
company called DoubleClick
and very much became
a technology company.
And so if you look on this map,
where I show up here is
that we're on the 2004, 2005
time frame, I was a client and
hired Performics to be my
global search partner.
Ironically, about that same
time, guess what happened?
DoubleClick became industry
standard and Google acquired
the company.
And I think we always knew that
Google would spit out the
services component and keep
the technology components,
because it would be a
conflict of interest
if that didn't happen.
Little did I know, back during
that time, that I would end up
back at Performics.
Had no idea at the time.
So I could go on.
So obviously, if you think
back to your history with
Performics, up until the
Motorola acquisition, the
Performics DoubleClick
acquisition was the largest
that Google has ever acquired.
But of course, now that
has been beaten.
But then Publicis came in and
bought the company about three
years ago--
no, four years ago --and really
housed the company at
its center for a while.
And I think the company was
pretty lost for a while.
And quite frankly, about that
time, if you think about the
whole history of Performics, it
had been bought, sold, and
merged four times
in five years.
That's a lot for a company
to endure.
And so, you can move on
to the next slide.
When I got the company, it
was in pretty bad shape.
Revenues weren't huge.
These are US numbers.
But we were losing money,
about 10% a
year, when I got it.
So the great news is very much
a turnaround type of story.
And if you look at Performics
today, we are in 19 markets.
We'll end the year with 19
markets globally and around
700 employees.
So that's the company
that I manage today.
Doing very well and, I think,
really turning the corner, in
terms of establishing itself
as a global performance
marketing company.
And certainly a very key, good
partner for Google as well.
So I want to talk less about
Performics and more about some
of the issues that we're facing
in the workplace today.
And this is a topic that's near
and dear to my heart.
We'll talk about the fact that
I have a book coming out on
marketing this month,
actually.
In fact, I just got a note today
from one of the senior
editors at Audible.
And I get to go read my book and
record it in audio format
in the next few weeks,
which was exciting.
I always thought I would write
a historical novel.
But no, I wrote a boring
business book.
And once you learn to play this
book game, I'm actually
in the process of writing
a book about women
in leadership next.
Because I think it's
really important.
And there are some lessons
that I've learned in this
process that I can help maybe
translate, not just for women,
but I think for all of us that
are really struggling with
that somewhat in our
roles today.
And I wanted to talk
more about that.
It's also near and dear to
my heart because I've
superimposed my daughter's
photograph onto this
graduation.
She has 15 days of
school left.
And she will graduate
from college.
I have one son who is 25.
She's 23.
And then my youngest
son is 19.
So they're all gone.
But my daughter is out
to conquer the world.
In fact, recently she came and
spent a week at Performics.
She majored in psychology.
I always thought that she would
be great in marketing.
But she kind of poo-pooed that
all along, went and explored
physical therapy for awhile.
Then she spent a week
at Performics and
decided she loved it.
And she wanted to work for me.
And I said no, you can't.
And so my boss happened to be
there the week that she spent
the week at Performics.
And he said, so, did you
get what you want?
And she said, yes.
And he said, well, what
are you going to do?
And she said, I'm going to go
to work for a competitor and
kick my mom's ass.
So she thinks everything's
great.
And she has no issues.
And she does not see that she
has any barriers, which I
think is fantastic.
And she will be a
great success.
But if you go on and look at
the numbers, they're not as
rosy as you might think.
So since Performics is so much
of a data company and you guys
are so much of a data company,
I thought I would
start with the data.
Which really, if you look at
some of these statistics, we
haven't moved a lot in the
last 40 years, honestly.
We've been hugely responsible
women in the workforce for the
growth of the GDP in the US.
It's a tremendous contribution
that women have made.
But you look at the very top
50% of the workforce,
obviously 52% is women.
Graduate rates are fantastic.
But as you move up the food
chain-- and I certainly
experience this every day--
it's bleaker and bleaker.
And there's a lot of
reasons for that.
I think a lot of it is--
and many women are talking
about this--
the struggle in managing your
family and all the different
roles that we make.
We have a tough time balancing
all those things.
In my industry--
advertising and marketing--
director level and above, the
average percentage of women
holding that is 4%.
4%.
In an industry where clearly
we're marketing to 85% of the
decision makers who happen to
be women today, which is
really pretty sad.
On a very near and dear topic
to me, since I'm in the
process of marketing a book, I
had a great idea for a book
that I've been talking
about since 2007.
I actually bought the URL
in 2007 for the concept.
Had a hell of a time
selling it.
And why did I have a hell
of a time selling it?
Because I'm a woman author
in a B2B space.
And why is that important?
It's important because all
women read more than men.
But they don't read
[INAUDIBLE].
So I think what's really
important though, and more
important than probably the
numbers, is the story behind
the numbers.
And that is what's
really happening
to these young women.
And it's something that
I take an interest in.
Because if you look at Publicis
group as a whole, we
have almost 70% of the entering
workforce in the
beginning of their careers, as
people are coming out of
college, are women.
And then you get to the
top and that director
level, and it's 2%.
And so, where we're really
losing those women are in
their mid 30s to early 40s
when they are really
struggling, I think,
with that balance.
And I took a couple
of quotes here.
I've done several panels with
Wendy Clark at Coke, who's
just a great woman
to work with.
And she very much has a
passion around this
space for Coke, too.
But her quote is "Middle- and
upper-middle-management levels
are rich with female talent,
but very thin at the top.
The ready in a few years and
ready in five year buckets are
often rich with women, making
the company feel very good
about its prospects.
But the 'ready now' bucket
is year after year."
So this is the great Romney,
I have tons of
women in binders, right?
Great.
Let's try to get the women out
of the binders, shall we?
That's the most important thing
that we can do to really
support women, is try to figure
out how to get them to
that next spot and
make that happen.
So I brought a couple examples
to really talk about some of
the struggles, I think,
with women.
And one of the struggles
is the style and
the leadership style.
There's a lot of scientific
evidence and there's a great
study that McKinsey has done
in the last couple years
around what's going on in
women and leadership.
And I think one of the biggest
things is that women just
naturally don't have the agentic
style that people
think in their heads
of leaders.
So we're culturally trained to
think of a leader acting or
behaving in a certain way.
And I think for women, it's
really tough to try to figure
out what that right style is.
You have one style
here, whether you
agree with it or not.
She had a very specific style.
And I think a lot of people
criticized more for her style
than perhaps anything else.
And then here's another one
very familiar to you.
Another style that's being
somewhat criticized.
If you think of what she's known
for in the public now,
it's really the fact that
she didn't take time
off with her child.
And so there's a big spectrum
there that we
are swinging between.
And I think part of that's
reflective of the role change
that's happening not just for
women, but also for you guys.
Even for guys here, right?
So for example, I couldn't do
what I do at all without my
husband being willing
to do what he does.
But somebody had to stay home.
Because both parents can't
be gone all the time.
And yet, that's a
difficult role.
He'll go play golf during the
day, and the guys will say,
well, why are you here?
He's playing with 85-year-old
guys.
[LAUGHTER]
They're like, why
are you here?
It's a role that he's
grown into and
he's comfortable with.
But clearly it's not necessarily
the social norm,
if you will.
As I moved into doing the
research for this next book, I
went back and started to read
some of my books that I read
when I was 18, when I was
19, and many of my
women's study books.
And I reread "The Feminine
Mystique," which I think is
very relevant, given the fact
that I've also just wrote an
advertising book.
And so the thought is to
put those together.
Because I think now is the
time for us all to really
figure out how we participate
this.
And not just for the advancement
of women, but also
for the changing roles that
we have in order to be
successful, to keep our families
intact, and to keep
all of us successful and happy
and content in the workplace.
And part of this is, like I
mentioned, our changing roles.
If you think about every single
day, I wear a whole
bunch of different hats.
I could be a mom.
I could be a daughter.
I could be a wife.
I could be a friend.
I'm dealing with maybe one
of my horse issues.
I have horses too.
And so that's confusing
for people.
It's confusing for
me sometimes.
Which hat am I wearing?
And so if it's confusing for
me, it's probably confusing
for somebody who is
dealing with me.
It's like, well, who's
that person?
Right?
Because I can remember my kids
telling me when they were very
little, my daughter would listen
to me on the phone and
she would say, you're very
interesting when
you're on a work call.
That person is a different
person than she's used to.
And that's true.
I think all of us wear these
different hats multiple times
a day, all the time
during the day.
And that's just the reality of
the world that we live in
today, in order for our
own survival, that
we have to do that.
So as you can see this show up
in the McKinsey Study, 96% of
Fortune 1000 executives, women
executives, rated it critical
or fairly important to develop
a managing style with which
male managers are comfortable.
And that isn't easy.
And so Carol Bartz and Marissa
may be managing those.
And it's hard.
I would say I hate to judge
their decisions.
Because I have empathy for them,
trying to figure out
what that balance was.
I was telling Robin earlier that
my latest review that I
had with my boss, he had great
things to say about
me, which was great.
Especially my business
results.
He couldn't complain
about that.
But he said that I could be very
smart and very articulate
at times, and that could be very
intimidating, and that I
could also be very charming and
I needed to be charming
more often.
And so I was thinking,
OK, smart
and articulate, charming.
Smart and articulate,
charming.
Which one am I go to choose?
And it's hard to determine what
situation I choose, or
how I will be judged.
And it's not being judged
just by men.
It's being judged by women.
And quite frankly, women are
probably my harsher critics,
as a leader, than men are.
Because they're judging
me for whatever.
The higher I get, I could just
not say hello to someone or
look unhappy one day and someone
may take that and take
offense to it or make an
assumption that isn't true.
I just have to understand that
that's an impression that, as
I become more important,
becomes more visible.
And I need to be conscious
of that.
And that's hard.
It's hard as a woman, I think,
because we don't necessarily
fit the cultural style that
everyone expects us
to fit in the box.
So my thesis for you-- and my
book is called Marketing in
the Participation Age-- and so
all of the people that I work
with know I have a passion
around this whole notion of
participation.
And when I set about this thesis
was about the time that
Robin talked about when we did
Project Direct, in fact, where
I talked about Project
Direct in my book.
But also, it was about a time
when we did a big launch for
the printer group at HP.
And I started to try to figure
out how to integrate a
marketing program.
And by the time I invited all
the people that needed to be
involved in that integration,
there was about 60 people--
that was agencies and internal
HP people that needed to be
invited to the meeting to
actually plan an integrated
program for the US.
And that was because
everything was so
interrelated suddenly.
And I really also understood
the notion that, as a
marketer, I was not really
in charge of
integration any longer.
The burden really was on what
we used to call "the
consumer," lovingly.
And I always thought myself
as a consumer advocate.
I still do, actually, because
I think it's great
to wear that hat.
But sometimes a language change
prompts people to think
about a behavior change
that will follow.
And so my thesis here is to ban
the word "consumer" and
replace it with the word
"participant." And if you
really want someone to
participate with you, which is
really about a relationship,
it's about a long term
exchange, then how you
motivate people to
participate, there is
a formula for that.
And it's a human formula.
It's something that's
never been applied
to marketing before.
It's been applied
to education.
It's been applied to
human resources.
It's what keeps people
coming back to work.
And so that's the thesis of the
book, is taking those core
three tenants of
self-determination theory,
which is all sociology and
psychology, and applying it to
a marketing formula that's
relevant for today's era when
people really expect to have a
relationship with a brand.
Not just be sent a one-way
message that suddenly will
persuade them to do something or
change their mindset, which
is not really relevant.
But unfortunately, all of our
marketing principles have been
based upon that theory for
the last 60 years.
Because that's the way marketing
used to work.
And it just no longer
works that way.
And what's great about how this
relates to women is that
we just naturally are
participation catalysts.
So it's so ironic, because we
didn't talk about this.
But you introduced me as a
participation catalyst, right?
As someone who is talented for
bringing people together, to
collaborate with one another, to
try to figure out what that
vision is, to get people to
work with one another.
And we just are naturally
wired.
In fact, there's quite a few
books out there about women
who are good at collaborating.
And in fact, I didn't have
anything to do with this.
But about a year ago, Hillary
Clinton came out and talked
about the fact that we're
entering the participation age
and how important women are
globally in that era.
So the fact that we are all
wanting to be contributors,
because we have technology
that has enabled us to be
contributors and to interact
and have relationships with
one another, as well
as with brands.
And if you look at simple
things, like the four P's that
used to be so much dictated
by the brands,
they just aren't anymore.
They're very much
dictated by us.
Because we're all
participants.
And so as women, we have a
special opportunity for us to,
in this age of participation,
to be really talented and
bring together people to deliver
great results on
whatever we're doing in the
workplace, as well as in the
community, as well as
with our families.
The time now really is for us.
You can go on to the next one.
So I thought I'd leave
you with three
things to think about.
And there could have
been a mini three.
But I just thought, in terms
of the spirit of
participation, these are the
three that, as a woman, as a
leader, as a contributor, as a
participant, are things that I
try to keep in mind.
So the first one is really the
gift of seeing opportunity.
So not only are we great
collaborators, but we also, as
women, tend to see what
something could be versus what
it really is.
And I think that's a gift.
It's a gift in my horses that
I used to raise here.
So this horse-- you see my
husband in the background with
his hands on his hips.
And this horse, everyone in
the household called this
horse shithead.
That was not his name.
But that's what they saw is this
very obstinate creature.
He was a young child, so he
needed some guidance.
And what I saw was something
that was very
different than that.
I saw the horse that he could
be with a little bit of care
and some guidance and some
nurturing, if you will.
And I think that is something
that we're very good at.
And in fact, there are some
studies that reflect that
boards tend to hire women
in turnarounds more
than they hire men.
And part of that is, I think,
our ability to really see the
beauty in something and see what
it can become, and become
driven and motivated by getting
it to that point.
And I can tell you, I didn't
know that about myself,
really, until I took
Performics on.
And I didn't know Performics was
in such bad shape until I
got it and I had the problem
that I had to deal with.
But I loved it.
And honestly, I would do
a turnaround again.
There is something very
addictive and
satisfying about that.
And then, once I recognized
that, I started to see how I
did that in so many other parts
of my life that I didn't
really recognize before.
So that's one, the gift of
seeing the opportunity.
The second one is negotiate--
knowing what you want
and speak up.
So I always counsel this in
my young women leaders.
Because they tend not to speak
up for themselves.
I tend not to speak up
for myself, honestly.
I tend not to necessarily
negotiate or
ask for what I want.
And that's something I think
you all need to learn, that
that's the way the
world is played.
And don't feel shy about that.
And the other thing I would say
is if there is a position
that you want or that you're
looking at, if it doesn't
scare you, I wouldn't do it.
Because that's when we really
grow the most is when we're
afraid and when we're a little
frightened by something.
Because if it's not scaring you,
then it's probably not a
big enough opportunity
for you.
And I learned that right out
of the gate when I left HP.
Because I probably didn't
understand the full value of
contribution that
I could make.
And I left HP first and went to
Moxie Interactive as an SVP
running three departments.
And about three months into it,
I thought I way undershot.
I could be doing a lot more.
And so, it scared me, but
probably not enough.
This role scared me a lot more.
[LAUGHTER]
And I did fine, right?
So speak up for yourself.
Negotiate.
Ask for what you want.
And don't be afraid
to be afraid.
Don't be afraid to let something
[INAUDIBLE].
Lastly is be an advocate
for other women.
Like I say, my biggest critics
sometimes are other women.
And part of that is a phenomenon
that's called
horizontal violence
that's well known.
It's why more black men
kill other black men.
If someone's in a one-down
position, then it's just
naturally culturally to try to
drag someone else down, if
you're not in that
leadership role.
But if we can't be advocates for
ourselves, it's hard for
us to have others be
advocates for us.
And so I say that, and I remind
myself of this a lot.
Because I can look at a Carol
Bartz and criticize her
management style, because I
certainly can't relate to her
management style or leadership
style that she seemed to have.
But who am I to judge?
Maybe that's what felt right
to her and worked for her.
And so I am asking you all
to give each other a
break at any level.
Try to support women around
you, below you, above you,
beside you.
And those women business authors
out there, I'm asking
for your help.
Because we need to support
one another first.
And I think it's hard for us to
ask for others to support
us if we're willing
not to do that.
And that's it.
This is how you can
get a hold of me.
I will connect with any
and all of you.
I will talk to any and
all of you any time.
So don't be shy.
Don't be afraid to do that.
And I will answer any of your
questions, if you have them.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[INAUDIBLE]
career [INAUDIBLE]
I fear [INAUDIBLE]
sort of speak to that
[INAUDIBLE] career that's sort
of like, I've got my 10 years
in, and I'm a few years in and
I'm looking [INAUDIBLE].
DAINA MIDDLETON: And I think
you're exactly right.
This is part of the "speak up.
But also don't be afraid to tell
your boss and others what
you have done.
And I just don't think
we do that naturally.
So we do naturally nurture our
teams and grow our teams.
But you get to a point where you
have to manage down and up
at the same time.
And I honestly still
struggle with this.
I will tell you I struggle
with this.
Because I have created
at Performics a very
collaborative, transparent,
authentic, open, nurturing
environment.
But when I turnaround and go
deal with either my peers or
my boss, I cannot
act that way.
Because I will not
be successful.
So I continually have to act in
a bipolar way, sometimes on
the same issue.
I will be dealing with the same
issue below me, but then
have to go advocate up and an
act completely different.
Because the one thing I think,
also, that women don't
understand is we problem
solve by
soundboarding with one another.
Right?
If you have a problem, you
go test your theory.
And it's not because you can't
solve your problems.
It's because you're looking
for that input.
And that's how you
make a decision.
If you do that with a man
though, they assume you don't
know how to solve
your problems.
So I'll do this with
my husband.
I'll tell him, sit on
your fix-it card.
I don't need it today.
I just want a soundboard
with you.
And then, once I do that, he's
like, OK, phew, phew.
Because otherwise, he's like,
OK, did you do this?
Did you that?
Did you do this?
And I'm like, no.
I don't want any of that.
I just want you to listen.
I've actually seen three women
lose their jobs, because their
bosses thought that they
couldn't solve problems.
And it was purely the way they
approached the problem solving.
And so you right.
This is what is inspiring me to
write the book is that I do
think these little nuanced
things become really critical
at a certain point
in your career.
And it means either success
or failure if you don't.
And they're very small.
And they're very subtle.
But they're very important.
PRESENTER 2: If you do have
questions, can you raise your
hand and pass the mic
around so we can
capture on the recording?
DAINA MIDDLETON: Somebody
else had a question.
Who was it?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thank you.
This is really, really
interesting.
So I have two little kids, as I
know a lot of people in the
room here do.
And so I'm just curious, with
three little kids, that must
have been so hectic.
Did you ever take a step
back in your career?
Or were you always pretty
focused on the end goal and
knowing where you
wanted to be?
DAINA MIDDLETON: If someone
would have asked me 10, 15
years ago, I never would have
said I wanted to be a CEO or I
was going to lead a company.
I couldn't have told
you that at all.
I always was inspired by my
career and wanted to do that.
But to tell you even more, my
oldest is my husband's.
The younger two are mine.
I lost my first husband.
He died when they were
two and six.
So I was the primary
breadwinner.
So I didn't really
have a choice.
Some women have a choice
of whether they want
to just step back.
I didn't have that choice.
And maybe that's what continued
to drive me.
And I didn't have
family local.
I can remember sometimes,
because I had to travel, my
friends kind of shopped out my
kids, and they would spend the
night there.
And I remember picking
them up one night.
And my daughter said, OK, who
are we staying with tonight?
And I was like, me.
[LAUGHTER]
And that was really hard.
All those times were
really hard.
And I don't know why I just kept
pushing forward and not
thinking about it.
But I do think that something
that, as now a leader in an
organization, that we
need to give women
permission to do that.
Because I think that's back to
Wendy Clark's comment of when
we're bucketizing people for
succession planning, and they
don't necessarily fit the
profile for the timing or
whatever that someone else
has in mind, that's OK.
And we need to let that be OK.
And that's actually not
just for women.
That's for men too.
We need to figure out how better
to allow people to take
detours or, perhaps even stay at
the same level for a while
and that be OK, not just
continually progress.
But I will also tell you that I
think if I hadn't have left
HP, I never would
have progressed.
Because I think there
are two things.
One is, I had pigeonholed myself
in terms of what I
thought that I could do.
And I think they had also
pigeonholed in their minds
what I thought I
was capable of.
And that's a hard thing.
And I couldn't see that until
I got out of there.
So I think all those
things are factors.
And I don't know that any
of them are easy.
But, yeah, there were many times
where I thought, how am
I going to do all these
things that I'm doing?
And I just barely would make the
wire on every single thing
in your life.
After a while, that gets
exhausting, right?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm just going to piggyback
off that.
Because your story is actually
really interesting to me.
Because I love horses, too.
And I'm young, but I do want
to have a family one day.
And so I'm curious as to how you
balance things right now.
Because I know that if I'm
really heavy into work, that
lasts for a month, and then
my energy is shot.
And so if I force myself to
spend time with horses, then I
have more energy at work,
and the balance works.
But at your level, what is an
average week look like in
terms of the time you've found
necessary to dedicate to work
in order to get done what
you want to get done?
DAINA MIDDLETON: I'm probably
not a good example of balance
right now, honestly.
I'm very lucky that
I love what I do.
So that's the first thing, is
that if work was what we
described it to be-- work--
it would be different.
But I love what I do.
I'm passionate about
what I do.
I think about it all the time.
My brain probably
never shuts off.
But it is one reason I refuse
to live in New York-- and
Robin knows this very well--
or Chicago or San Francisco.
I live in Alta, Wyoming.
And part of that is because
there is a part of me that
needs that in order to
be the rest of me.
And I've been pretty
successful at
drawing that line.
I get a lot of criticism for
it, to a certain extent.
Because they're like,
you live where?
But I have a global job.
I could be anywhere.
And actually, when I ran the US
operations, I was actually
flying to Chicago every
Monday and flying home
every Thursday night.
And I had an apartment
in Chicago.
And I spent a fair amount
of weekends there.
And that was really hard.
And there were things
that suffered as a
consequence of that.
But it was what the business
needed at the time.
And it was the choice that
I made at the time.
But I will not lie to you that
my relationship suffered with
my husband, I would say.
My kids were fine, because
they're old enough.
They might tell you I may
have missed some things.
But it's really hard to
continually balance.
And I think it's constantly
making those decisions about
what's important to you.
Because you're right.
We're only human.
I think technology has also made
us feel like we can do
more somehow.
But we are, at the end of
the day, still human.
And we can't do everything
at once.
But when I get to go home-- and
right now, I'm trying to
run-walk four miles every
day with the dog.
And I try to ride my horse
as much as I can.
I have him boarded right
now, which I hate.
But it's the right thing for
him and the right thing for
me, right now.
And so I try not to let that
bother me as much as it
probably would normally
bother me.
He's in the Taj Mahal,
basically.
[LAUGHTER]
And he's kind of freaked
out about it.
And I'm kind of freaked
And we don't necessarily mix
well with the other people
that are there.
But it is what it is.
And I try to go and enjoy the
time that I have with him and
not stress out about the fact
that it's not perfect.
Because I think we're our
own worst enemy, right?
Same thing with my
husband at home.
So I like to be involved in
every decision and every
detail, because that's
who I am.
I can't do that.
Because A, it's not
fair to him.
And he might not do something
the way I would do it.
But I have to just let them do
it, because that's only fair.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming in.
I have a couple questions.
The first one, I'm curious to
hear about the jump that you
made, having been at
HP for so long.
And you said you went
somewhere else.
And then to become the
CEO of Performics.
I'd love to hear more about
what that looked
like on your end.
And then I'd also love to hear
about mentors and how that's
played a role in your career.
DAINA MIDDLETON: Sure.
So like I said, I was
at HP 16 years.
I did play a number
of roles there.
I think that's the nice
thing about tech.
And I'm sure you experience
it, is that I was probably
never in any role longer
than two years.
So I got a lot of change and a
lot of variety and a lot of
investment in me that I
probably, actually value way
more now than I did
at the time.
I was lucky enough that that
was a time when HP, as a
company, was investing so
much in their people.
I don't think that's
the case today.
So I had all that.
And the whole notion of this
book and this idea that I
had-- and I had many ideas
that I wanted to test--
and I felt like I could do that
better outside of HP than
I could inside.
And so I happen to meet the CEO
and founder, another woman
actually, used to be
named Kris Zagoria.
Her name's Pinto.
She's recently changed
her name.
But she agreed to allow me to
come experiment with some of
my ideas at Moxie, which was
a great opportunity.
And I just decided
to take the leap.
But I was afraid.
And I was so loyal to HP,
because having been there so
long, and they'd really
been my family
through a lot of time.
But I also recognized the
fact that I wasn't
going to get any higher.
I just didn't see management
view me that way.
And so that's when I left.
Now, I was a Moxie two years.
And I had kept saying, Google
is going to get rid of
Performics.
Publicis should pick
up Performics--
great company.
And everyone kept saying, no,
they bought Pole Nord.
Not going to buy another
search company.
Well, lo and behold,
it happened.
And shortly after that, of
course, Zenith, we were
looking to align Performics
with more of the Zenith
family, which is where I fit
within the Publicis family.
And my boss at the time said,
well, it's too bad you don't
want to run a search company.
I said, well, what you mean it's
too bad I don't want to
run a search company?
He said, well, it's located
in Chicago.
Well, my team was sitting
in Atlanta at the time.
And I was living in
Boise, Idaho.
And I said, well, Chicago's
a lot easier than Atlanta.
It's a direct shot.
And so I kind of threw my name
in that hat at that point.
And there was another candidate
that was being
considered within the family.
But ultimately, I was chosen.
I think I went through two
interview processes.
And there were people that
actually had worked on my
account at HP that still
work for the company.
And I ran into two of them in
my two visits, which I was
trying to keep it nice.
And I said, oh, hi, I'm
in the family now.
But that's how I got there.
And then, when the global role
came about as well, so I
managed the US operation
for again, two years.
And so I've been doing the
global role for about a year
now-- a year in January.
PRESENTER 1: So while you were
running the US operation, you
really transformed the culture
of Performics.
And I think it was rated as the
number one place to work
in Chicago.
DAINA MIDDLETON: Number four for
all women, number eight in
advertising for "AdAge"
overall.
We have about seven awards now
for best places to work.
Yes.
PRESENTER 1: So what
did you do?
DAINA MIDDLETON: Well, that's
back to the transparent,
authentic, open.
So one of the things I learned
really quickly, even with my
own management team, is it was
a very hierarchical, almost
militaristic culture.
And I didn't realize that
when I came in.
In fact, the first staff meeting
I had with my team, I
think I talked through things.
And then, the second staff
meeting I said, OK, I'm going
to talk less.
And I'll let you guys talk.
And they all froze.
And they're like, well,
we're not prepared.
And I'm like, I don't want
you to prepare anything.
We're smart people.
We need to benefit
from one another.
But that's an example of
there was this really
very damaging culture.
There were the haves
and have-nots.
So it took a long time
to transform that.
You can't culture something.
To me, that's more like
gardening than it is--
I just can't say, great
culture now.
It's more like cultivate the
soil, spread the seeds, water,
fret over it a bit, continue
to nurture and grow that.
And one of the things I did
right off the bat is started a
"to all employees" email
every other week.
And they named it Daina's
Download, just telling people
what was going on.
Because that was the problem is
there was all this secrecy.
We were losing people.
It's hard to keep people in
our industry, as you know.
There's generally
at 30% turnover.
We had higher than that
when I got there.
I also did a survey of
all of my team and
asked them five questions.
What was good?
What were the barriers?
What was bad?
What needed to be changed?
And so we consciously started
working on all of those
different things and then
establishing a vision.
Because the company just
hadn't had a vision.
Because basically, they had just
changed their logo five
times in four years.
And they didn't really
know what they
stood for in that process.
And so it took a while
to turn that around.
Now it's paying off.
I think our attrition rate is
about 11% the last two years,
which is probably
pretty healthy.
And yes, the workplace awards
are all employee survey.
We applied to be on the list.
And then, I think a certain
number of employees have to
respond back to get you
on the short list.
And then once you're on the
short list, you get a bunch of
questionnaires.
I think Google is on the list,
and Chicago as well, actually.
So it takes time.
It takes work.
It takes constant effort.
It's constant care
and feeding.
It is like having a garden
all the time.
AUDIENCE: I had one more
question on mentorship.
If there have been any mentors
that have been really
impactful to you.
DAINA MIDDLETON: You asked
me about that.
AUDIENCE: If you could
share that.
DAINA MIDDLETON: My mom was
a huge inspiration.
I think she was the only person
in the family that had
ever gotten a college
degree at all.
And she's one credit away
from a doctorate.
She was an educator.
So she was my teacher
in the eighth grade.
She would not let me call her
"mom." I had to call her
"Mrs." And she constantly
pushed me and basically
instilled in me that I could
do whatever I wanted to.
So I think that laid
the foundation.
And then what I have found is
there have been many women,
along the way.
It's kind of like what
Robin was saying.
There have been women
that I watched and
learned from by watching.
And I've seen this over
and over again.
Well, I'll be enchanted by that
person and kind of watch
and learn from.
And then it's like a cycle.
And then you get to the point
where it's like, ooh, I'm also
learning what not to do
from them as well.
And then you go on
to the next one.
And I think that's OK, in your
career, to have multiple
leaders, both men and women,
that inspire you in different
ways and motivate you
in different ways.
I've never really had a formal
mentor, if you will, or coach.
AUDIENCE: Follow and watch.
What does that mean?
DAINA MIDDLETON: Either people
you work for you.
You watch them in meetings.
You watch them interact.
You watch how they interact
with you and employees.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAINA MIDDLETON: Yeah.
The results of the drive.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
we were going to watch
or follow [INAUDIBLE]
DAINA MIDDLETON: Yeah.
All the women that I've
had are women or
other leaders, actually--
they haven't all been women--
who I've worked alongside
with.
I think it's really hard.
There have been people like
Katharine Graham, I think, was
a huge inspiration to me growing
up, because I have a
journalism degree.
And just what she did,
in her time period.
For those of you don't know, she
was the one who led "The
Washington Post" during
Watergate.
And one of the most delightful
things was the fact that I got
to meet her daughter, who is
also named Katharine, who's
now running "The Washington
Post"-- her granddaughter
actually, which was great.
And so there have been people
from afar, but not a lot.
Because I think it's hard
to take those cues.
And it's hard.
I've had people ask me.
In fact, I just got a request
this week for someone to ask
for me to be a mentor.
And I'm happy to do that.
I think it's hard if that person
is not interacting with
you on a regular basis though.
Is there somebody else.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for being here
today with us.
It's really great.
I'm just curious, as you've
grown in your career and gone
into higher level roles, have
you ever found yourself in a
position where, especially as
a woman, people are maybe
doubting you or making
it difficult for
you in your new role?
And what did you do
to combat that?
DAINA MIDDLETON: Every
single day.
Every single day I may doubt
myself about something.
Maybe I just am obsessed
sometimes about some of the
decisions that I make.
I was saying this actually,
about Obama to my
husband this weekend.
I think early on in my
leadership, it was hard to
figure out when to compromise
and when to just say, no,
these are the things that are.
And I knew probably
instinctually or some way what
were the right decisions.
And I maybe hesitated sometimes
on which ones to
really be tough on.
Now, to be fair, my team now--
I haven't lost a single team
member since I took the reins
of leadership, which is
kind of amazing--
they will joke with me
about, when did you
know what you wanted?
And how come you were
so patient with us?
So part of it was,
it was probably
good that I was patient.
And I did probably
second-guess some of my questions.
Because I think I brought them
along in the change management
in a healthy way.
Whereas, if I would have said
tough, get over it, sometimes
that can actually reverse the
change management process.
But I definitely think I'm more
comfortable now, knowing
what to maybe spend more time
on and to kind of explore.
Because I think I may
want to go a certain
way and it may not.
I may not have all the
information versus I just say
no or yes on some things, and
this is what we're doing.
But that's just experience and
knowing yourself and knowing
your team and knowing whatever
you're working on.
And all those things get more
comfortable over time.
I'm probably way more
comfortable about that now
than I used to be.
AUDIENCE: Hey, this
has been great.
Thank you so much.
DAINA MIDDLETON: Oh,
you're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Finding the what you
love-- you mentioned what you
do every day doesn't
feel like work.
This may be going back to
before you were at HP.
But how did you narrow down or
figure out, this is what I
really love doing?
DAINA MIDDLETON: I have
no idea, honestly.
I honestly, probably stumbled
into a variety of things that
just one led to another
led to another.
And I will tell you that
about every two to
three years I get restless.
So I've never really been in a
role longer than three years,
I think, ever.
And I almost always change
roles in the spring.
[LAUGHTER]
You can look at my resume,
and it's weird.
Because it's like, April,
April, April, April.
And that was even at HP.
I don't know what that is.
But I definitely have a cycle
of restlessness in April.
And I think, just like going
into digital, it was purely an
instinctual thing, that I
thought, this is cool.
I stumbled into something that
I really, really enjoyed and
didn't think about
it too much.
I just headed for it.
In fact, Maurice Levy was
in our office yesterday.
He came to visit and
spent an hour.
And he spent about 10 minutes
with the entire organization.
And someone asked him
that question.
And this is a man who has been
at Publicis since he was 19
years old, and is close
to 80 now, I believe.
And incredibly sharp,
witty, chic.
I told him he looked chic
yesterday, if a
man nearly 80 could.
And he asked me, just
today I look chic?
[LAUGHTER]
But he said two things.
He said, have fun.
He said, if you aren't having
fun, you're not
in the right place.
And he said, be relentless.
Just continually aspire
to do better.
So that was it.
That was all.
He said he had also never
mapped his career.
Never knew where he was going.
He was having a good time.
And he was relentlessly
pursuing to be better.
And I think that's probably not
too bad advice, honestly.
It seemed to have
worked for him.
PRESENTER 1: Any questions
from the fellas?
DAINA MIDDLETON: I know, you
guys have been quiet.
AUDIENCE: I have three
daughters.
So this is great.
[LAUGHTER]
How do I continue to--
DAINA MIDDLETON: Heaven
help you.
AUDIENCE: --learn from
your experience.
DAINA MIDDLETON: I
only have one.
And I will tell you,
one was enough.
AUDIENCE: I guess, what, as
a man, clearly, and a male
manager, what things should we
ensure that we instill to the
up-and-coming women leaders?
What are some qualities that
we want to make sure that
we're reinforcing?
DAINA MIDDLETON: I think making
them aware where these
male and female stereotypes
get in the way.
It's like I say, this
decision-making thing is a
great example.
And there's probably others.
And neither understands it.
So I think as you--
and you're a very approachable
male manager--
can say, do you realize how
you're coming across?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Yeah.
DAINA MIDDLETON: And be honest
and open with that.
It's not in a mean way.
But we just can't see it.
We can't see that.
And the only reason I learned
some of this is HP had this
fantastic full-week, into
evening, multicultural
training program that I went
through that was fantastic.
And it went the gamut of every
cultural stereotype and some
of the kinks in different
cultures working with one
another that was amazing.
But nobody gets that anymore.
Nobody gets that level
of training.
So we all just stumble around.
So I think that's
the key thing.
And you already do
this so well.
Because you guys all
know, right?
He listens really well
without judging.
AUDIENCE: She's my client too.
[LAUGHTER]
DAINA MIDDLETON: Right?
And that's what most, I think,
women need more than anything,
is someone who can listen and
provide them with feedback.
[? Taka ?]
[? Ko. ?]
Hi.
All these people from
different lives.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank
you so much.
Good to see you here.
DAINA MIDDLETON: Good
to see you too.
AUDIENCE: So just kind
of a random question.
But what would you
be really looking
forward to in the morning?
Like, waking up, like,
wow, this is going
to be so much fun.
What really excites you now?
DAINA MIDDLETON: The biggest
thing that excites me is
there's a certain part
obvious [INAUDIBLE]
packed and so that are known,
that I know that
are going to happen.
But it's the unknowns
that excite me.
It's the things that I
absolutely know that something
will happen during the day that
I did not anticipate,
have no idea.
It's the complete unknowns.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I totally could
look this up.
So I apologize.
But I'm about to get my MBA.
And so I'm curious what
your opinion is on
graduate degree use.
Now I graduated from
undergrad in 2008.
And so a lot of my cohort went
back to school, because the
economy was horrible.
So part of my instinct is
telling me that by the time,
hopefully, I get to where your
level is, that's going to
become necessary in
a lot of ways--
like a deal breaker--
especially as a woman,
if you don't have it.
So I'm curious what your
thoughts are on that.
DAINA MIDDLETON: First of
all, congratulations.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAINA MIDDLETON: Because looking
back, it was probably
something I should have
investigated more and didn't
at the time.
I don't have a graduate
degree.
But it's certainly giving you
that rounded [INAUDIBLE]
always valuable.
And you have that business
practicality that I didn't
necessarily have from an
education standpoint.
I just had to learn it from
on-the-ground standpoint.
I hope it benefits you.
I don't think it's something
that we value in our career.
I just don't think we're
necessarily looking for it.
We probably value experience
more than we
value education now.
And that's not necessarily
a good thing.
But it is just a reality
of where we are.
AUDIENCE: So you haven't seen,
at least in where you're at
right now, that being a blockade
for people moving up?
DAINA MIDDLETON: Nope.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAINA MIDDLETON: Nope,
not at all.
But like I say, that business
management component that you
have, the finance in particular
probably, it will
benefit you.
Because ultimately, that's how
you're going to have to put
your results is into
that frame.
And I had to learn that.
I had to learn to put my bar
chart in my resume, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
DAINA MIDDLETON: When I left HP,
probably, I had a resume
that was not a results-based
resume.
It was a skills-based
resume, I would say.
It basically described
the roles that I had.
It didn't describe the results
that I delivered.
And I can tell you, my resume
today is 100% results driven.
Of course, I am in a company
called Performics, so.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one more question?
DAINA MIDDLETON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So what would you say
was your biggest hurdle
that you had to overcome?
DAINA MIDDLETON: My own
confidence in myself.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess, on that
note, [INAUDIBLE] talk a
little bit about [INAUDIBLE]
yourself, in times past.
Do you get intimidated?
Do you feel like you get
intimidated still in
situations?
Or do you recall times in which
you were intimidated?
And how did you blow past it?
DAINA MIDDLETON: I don't
know if intimidate
is the right word.
Certainly I experienced
that in the a past.
Today, I'm probably less
intimidated, but still
probably question sometimes my
decisions, especially if
they're hard people decisions.
If I have to fire somebody,
those are the hardest
decisions for me.
Because they really impact
a human's life in
a meaningful way.
And so you better believe that
I'm going to second guess
that, think twice about
it, feel bad about it.
But honestly, the day that I
don't, I need to just go home.
Because I should feel
those things about
those types of decisions.
Right?
Obviously, there are moments
where I will feel frustrated.
About three weeks ago, I
was working from home.
I had just about three
or four situations.
And my husband, he works
in the office over.
And he was like, are you
throwing things in there?
I said, yes.
And I'm going to take pictures
of the Tetons now.
I'll be back in two hours.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
But that's why, again,
I live where I live.
And I need that perspective.
But we all do that.
We're all humans.
That's what we have
to remember.
I don't care who you are, how
famous you are, how renowned
you are, how smart you think
someone is, we're all humans.
PRESENTER 1: Ask the question
and we'll--
AUDIENCE: Sure.
[INAUDIBLE]
DAINA MIDDLETON: Sure.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I'm having more on
how a male could be better
leader, from the female
perspective, especially with
your experience at the top.
What would you like to see your
male bosses do better?
Or do you have any thoughts
on how someone
could be a better leader?
DAINA MIDDLETON: Sure.
So my key partner in crime in
the US is the president.
And he is a guy.
Actually, almost all of my team
are guys, unfortunately.
I have a few key
woman leaders.
But probably the thing I
constantly remind him of is,
where I am probably more of an
inspirational leader who's
constantly driving that vision,
and I think if you
were to talk to my team-- in
fact, in these surveys, they
call me a mom in it.
And like a friend's mom, is what
they will say, in a nice
kind of way.
He is more about, let's
just get this done--
goals and objectives,
operational efficiency,
operational effectiveness.
And together we probably make
a whole human being.
So I think whatever you are,
balancing those things.
So I'm ever conscious that
my weaknesses are in the
operational side of making sure
that we have documented
and we're tracking goals and all
of those things that are
important and key.
But I don't want to lose
the other piece.
Because that also is
really important.
And you have to figure out
what's your strengths and
weaknesses.
Those tend to be male
characteristics.
But that's not always
the case.
So for example, recently
he got relentless
about this goal thing.
And every single staff meeting
that's all it was, was
tracking these objectives.
AUDIENCE: Eventually.
[LAUGHTER]
Eventually he handled
[INAUDIBLE]
DAINA MIDDLETON: And so I told
him, I said, OK, Eric.
Because he's really into this.
And he wants to drive it home.
And everyone said
they wanted it.
But the last time it got to
OK, so now we've done
individual goals.
We're going to do
cross-departmental goals.
And you could just feel the
oxygen leave the room.
But he was kind of impervious
to that.
Because he was on his mission.
And so I gently said,
I have a suggestion.
I said, for the next meeting,
let's bring
Tequila into the room.
I keep Tequila in my office--
nice Tequila actually.
Good Tequila.
Not US Tequila.
And so he did.
He listened.
We brought Tequila in.
We had a drink.
And everyone kind of bleh, let
it all out, to what their
frustration.
Because they had been
afraid to really
talk about their needs.
And afterwards he said, that
was a really good call.
Because he was totally
driven to his goal,
without taking the time.
Because not just women
in the room.
There were men the room, too,
that were so frustrated.
But he hadn't taken the time to
really step back and say,
OK, I'm leading, but is anyone
still following?
And I think that's a classic
male trait, is
to just bowl ahead.
And that's great.
But you've got to look behind
you every once in a while, and
then be sensitive to
what's going on.
And then I think that listening
component, too, I
think, is really important.
And being really open.
If you are going to say, I'm
willing to listen, be willing
to take the good and the bad.
Because some people,
like my boss,
will say, he's a listener.
But he really doesn't want to
hear anything that you're
going to say to him that
is a criticism.
He's not really interested
in that.
PRESENTER 1: Thank
you [INAUDIBLE].
DAINA MIDDLETON:
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Again, this was fun.
[LAUGHTER]